thanks to dashlane for keeping legal
eagle in the air
so you don't work on a contingency basis
no
money down oops shouldn't have this bar
association logo here either
yeah he's just the best worst lawyer of
all time
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer and today we are covering
one of my favorite episodes of one of my
favorite series of all time
it's the simpsons and it's the episode
where ichi and scratchy get taken to
court
for copyright infringement it's called
the day the violence died and while i
will be reacting to it i think i could
probably
quote this episode line for line it's
it's really that good it's one of my
favorites it involves lionel huts
no money down it's just it's just
it's fantastic so as always be sure to
comment in the form of an objection
which i will either sustain or overrule
and stick around until the end of the
episode where i give the simpsons the
day the violence died a grade for
legal realism so without further ado
let's dig into the simpsons
the day the violence died
[Music]
so the background of this episode is
that it is the 75th anniversary of itchy
and scratchy which is
a clear stand-in for disney a
much more violent version of the walt
disney corporation
and the town of springfield is throwing
a parade
for the creators of itchy and scratchy
which includes roger meyer senior
who's the guy who claims to have
invented itchy and scratchy
the parade goes into bum town where we
find
bart about to meet a bum who claims to
have invented itchy and scratchy himself
hey wait
[Music]
out of bum up you know talent bum your
bums
respect man that no talent created itchy
and scratchy
he didn't create itchy i did huh
he stole a character from me in 1928
when i complained his thugs kicked me
out of his office
and dropped an anvil on me
so this is interesting this is a normal
copyright issue
great issues going on already here you
have the theft
of intellectual property and purportedly
the theft of a character now a character
as apart from normal literary or
audio-visual work
can actually receive copyright
protection so for example we've seen
many times in litigation
that james bond has copyright protection
as a character
apart from all of the 30 or 40 james
bond movies that that character has
appeared in
so it is possible to quote unquote steal
a character from a copyright perspective
but remember
you cannot steal ideas ideas are not
copyrightable it's only the expression
itself and i think that's going to be
a big theme throughout this episode you
invented itchy the itchy and scratchy
itchy
sure in fact i invented the whole
concept of cartoon violin
before i came along all cartoon animals
did was play the ukulele
i changed all that well i'm not calling
you a liar but
but i can't think of a way to finish
that sentence
here we have another argument which is
that he invented the idea of
cartoon violence now that almost
certainly he would not be able to have
copyright protection over
the idea of cartoon violence or the idea
of a romantic comedy or the idea of a
sci-fi space opera
these are what we call scenes affair
which are not protectable they are
stock scenes that we see over and over
and over again in many different
industries
and different types of ip so he would
not be able to have a claim
for intellectual property over the idea
of cartoon violence even if
cartoon characters were only just
playing the ukulele before he came
along ichi the lucky mouse in manhattan
madness
that's the first issue cartoon ever made
and it was made by
me chester j lampwood find me a 90 year
old projector and i'll prove it to you
they go to this school
[Music]
okay so right off the bat this uh film
canister contains
uh the film of the original itchy and
scratchy cartoon
the thing is that is something that
lends
itself to a valid copyright the thing
about copyright is that
you don't have to petition the
government to get it there are reasons
why you would want to do that
but as soon as you put your expression
into a tangible
form that's supposed to be
semi-permanent or permanent
that is when you get the copyright in
the expression and this
film reel is going to be something that
could lend itself to
creating a copyright in this film itself
and in the character
itchy and or scratchy
[Music]
concept of cartoon violence invented
[Music]
oh so this is a great little tidbit here
it says copyright
that little c in the circle 1919.
in 1919 you actually had to put a
copyright
notice on any work that you had if you
didn't put
a copyright notice on your tangible
expression
then you would not get a copyright so
back in the day it was really really
important to have that little symbol to
let
everyone know that this was a
copyrighted work so if chester j
lampwick had not put that notice on his
film he would not have a copyright and
he wouldn't have any claim to the itchy
and scratchy fortune the united states
did away with that requirement in 1976
and the 1976 copyright act
which it really wasn't necessary at all
and it was a trap for the unwary to not
include a copyright notice in your
actual expression so
now you still get a copyright regardless
of whether you put the little c
with the the date that says that there's
a copyright on your particular work
that was itchy all right you did invent
him when people see this you'll be rich
and famous
yeah as an evidentiary issue that makes
it much much harder to prove your case
well that brought back a lot of memories
i can't believe it's a law firm okay
there are actual uh regulations that uh
prescribe
what lawyers are allowed to put in terms
of the name of their firms
and that name absolutely does not comply
with that and it sort of implies that
it's not
actually a law firm although query
whether
lionel hutz is actually an attorney in
the simpsons given
his his run-ins with the bar ugh lionel
hutz is my favorite character ever he's
so good
all right gentlemen i'll take your case
but i'm going to have to ask for a
thousand dollar retainer
a thousand dollars but your ad says no
money down
oh they got this all screwed up
as i've covered already on this channel
this is one of my favorite lawyer jokes
of
all time and it's it so plays into
lionel hutz as being the most ridiculous
terrible lawyer of all time this is such
a clear violation
of legal ethics where you can't put out
an ad like that to the public and then
completely redline it right in front of
your potential client
and claim that you only work with a
retainer and money down
but the way that it works is just so
perfect it's so good
so you don't work on a contingency basis
no
money down oops shouldn't have this bar
association logo here either
yeah he's just the best worst lawyer of
all time
i thought i recognized you i gave you a
plate of corn muffins back in 1947 to
paint my chicken coop
and you never did it those corn muffins
were lousy
paint my chicken coke make me
yeah that would be a totally enforceable
contract
corn muffins for painting the chicken
coop and
chester j lampwick would be in violation
of that contract for
not actually providing his labor i think
the statute of limitations is probably
run
there now that it's uh 80 years in the
future
but uh it would have been an enforceable
contract wait wait wait wait wait
there's an easy way to get rid of
chester without the guilt of sending him
back to the gutter
and all it will cost you is a thousand
dollars
got legal fees from some family okay
quick note
it is possible to bankroll someone
else's lawsuit now
traditionally historically that has been
illegal that's been what's called
champerty and that's been a violation of
legal ethics those rules have largely
been removed
and it is possible to bankroll someone
else's lawsuit this actually happened
very recently
when peter thiel the tech billionaire
financed hulk
hogan's lawsuit against gawker the
website for
publishing hulk hogan's sex tape this is
a part of a great book
by ryan holiday called conspiracy that
talks about
peter thiel wanting to get revenge
against gawker so he bankrolled this
lawsuit that eventually
bankrupted the gawker media enterprise
so
it is possible to do it is legal might
not be the nicest thing to do but you
are allowed to do it
exhibited steamboat itchy dated
1928 the very first itchy and scratchy
cartoon
and the credits clearly state written
directed and created by
roger myers music by roger myers and
george gershwin produced by roger myers
and joseph p kennedy
copyright 1928 by roger myers
so uh we've already talked about how
important that copyright notice
was i don't know why they are jumping
right to
closing argument here there would
normally be years of discovery
and motions on paper this is the sort of
thing that would be dealt with on
summary judgment
because there's no evidence on behalf of
chester j lambwick but as with most
fictional portrayals of legal
proceedings they're just skipping right
to the juicy parts
you will also notice mr maya's name and
copyright notice on the original
drawings of the other members of the
itchy and scratchy family
brown-nosed beer disgruntled goat
flatulent fox
rich uncle skeleton and dinner dog
my client's film predates all of those
things your honor
you can't argue in the middle of a
statement oh
yes i've forgotten your famous film
the one you destroyed before the trial
and haven't been able to find another
copy of
oh yes that film yes
you don't have a copy do you
now that sounds ridiculous and it is
ridiculous in the middle of trial like
that but
in real life lionel hutz would have been
able to
ask if the owners of itchy and scratchy
have old copies of the 1919 film
that is the basis for his claim and if
they did
they would be obligated to turn that
over now you might think that's crazy
that why would you turn over
uh negative evidence against yourself
well
the rules of civil discovery require you
to turn it over
because we don't want trial by ambush we
want everyone to put all of their cards
on the table and if
there's evidence that you have that's
bad for your case you have a duty to
turn that over to the other side if you
get to that
part of the discovery process so uh
lionel hutz
you know he's a terrible lawyer but you
know even a blind squirrel finds a nut
sometimes
so good job for him roger myers didn't
create any of his characters he stole
them all
[Music]
the only characters myers could ever
come up with were pathetic stick figures
with the words
sarcastic horse and manic mailman
printed on them
and they stank so who is the voice of
chester j lampwig that that sounds
really hold on a second i need to look
this up because that that guy sounds
really familiar
it's kirk douglas oh i didn't know that
that's fantastic
mr hutz we've been in here for four
hours do you have any evidence at all
well your honor we've got plenty of
hearsay and conjecture those are
kinds of evidence
that's actually true hearsay and
conjecture are kinds of
evidence uh they're not good forms of
evidence but technically they are
types of evidence many of the lawyers
that i know uh use that line
all the time it's a it's a staple among
lawyers it's fantastic
i knew i had seen this exact scene
somewhere else it was in the movie mr
lampwick showed me
ladies and gentlemen this drawing was
made in 1919
nine years before roger myers made his
first
itchy and scratchy cartoon
yeah but how do we know that that's
authentic there's a whole authentication
process that you have to go
through to prove that the evidence that
you are
putting forward is what it purports to
be i don't think
this this evidence would be admissible
at this point okay
maybe my dad did steal itchy but so what
animation is built on plagiarism if it
weren't for someone plagiarizing the
honeymooners
we wouldn't have the flintstones if
someone hadn't ripped off sergeant
bilcoe
there'd be no top cat huckleberry hog
chief wiggum yogi bear
andy griffith one of the all-time great
sight gags of the simpsons is to break
the fourth wall
and say that the idea of chief wiggum is
stolen from somewhere else
just just a plus and there's some truth
to what he's saying that
these characters are often homages and
uh frankly uh stolen from
other places so whether the
you get copyright protection over a
specific character itself
is is up for grabs and um not all taking
is illegal not all copying is illegal
well
itchy and scratchy are gone but here's a
cartoon that tries to make learning fun
[Music]
sorry about this kid i know what this is
this is one of the most brilliantly
written parodies of all time
i can sing this entire song hey who left
all this garbage on the steps of
congress
i'm not garbage i'm an amendment
and i'm hoping that they'll ratify me
there's a lot of flag burners who have
got too much freedom
i want to make it first amendment
[Music]
violations
at least i hope and pray that
[Music]
dad can we have 183 000
what for listen i want to finance a
series of animated cartoons
oh forget it animation legal precedent
copyright law 1918 in 1923. that is such
a great little detail there because
there actually was an amendment to the
copyright act in 1923
that changed copyright law and in fact
because of the change in copyright law
all works before 1923 are out of
copyright so
ironically although the litigation over
this case
of a copyright from 1919 is raging
in this episode now looking back
all of this would be out of copyright
the the copyright in itchy and scratchy
would be
null and void and all of that stuff
would have entered into the public
domain so it's a great little detail
that they
are looking at the correct copyright law
for the time
and since the work was created in 1919
you'd have to look at
the law that existed before the
copyright act of 1923 because that's how
you sort of retroactively apply the law
just just from top to bottom one of the
best simpsons episodes of all time
when no one could think of a plan to
resurrect
itsy and scratchy a young boy a
wonderful irrepressible young boy
took it on his own to solve the problem
he discovered that the postal service's
mrs zip was just a ripoff of my father's
stick figure character
manic mailman so the government
gave me a huge cash settlement
so that sounds totally ridiculous and
there are still the questions of whether
you could even have a copyright in
a not really thought out character like
that but a situation almost exactly like
that actually did happen in a famous
case
involving the us postal service the u.s
postal service created a stamp where
they took a photo
of the korean war memorial in washington
d.c which
is a series of statues with soldiers who
are wading through the snow
and they put it on a stamp the thing is
the artist who created the statues
still had a copyright in the statues you
can have a copyright in statutes just
like you can have a copyright in
paintings or or a novel so
when they created this stamp without his
permission they committed copyright
infringement in the same way
that the u.s postal service supposedly
created
copyright infringement in this
particular case so
things like that actually do happen and
you can sometimes get a big cash
settlement from the government when they
involve copyright infringement and itchy
and scratchy studios
is back in business
thanks to you lester
[Music]
what the hell is going on and they
end the episode poking fun at the fact
that their own characters are derivative
just
so good
[Music]
but now it's time to give this episode
of the simpsons a grade for legal
realism
so on the one hand you have a brilliant
story involving
uh some really detailed aspects of
copyright law that you really don't see
all that often
and for the most part it gets the
copyright stuff exactly right right down
to the dates
involved where the copyright law changed
you have
probably one of the best depictions of a
schoolhouse rock parody that is
not only i think hilarious but exactly
right on first amendment law
but on the other hand you have a trial
that is abbreviated to be
the shortest trial known to man without
any of the boring parts
and the worst lawyer known to man in the
form of lionel hutz but in some sense
the writers must know what they're doing
because there's no way to write a lawyer
that bad
without knowing what a lawyer should do
so all in all
i will give this episode of the simpsons
an a minus
maybe i'm giving them a high grade just
because i love this episode so
so much but it's my show and i can do
whatever i want
there's something unsettling about that
the ideas for itchy and scratchy may
have been stolen but your passwords and
payment information
should never be and dashlane gives you
an all-in-one tool to protect yourself
online
dashlane syncs all of your passwords and
payment details between all of your
devices without ever knowing those
passwords
when you sign up for dashlane you choose
a master password that is never
transmitted over the internet not even
dashlane to their servers has your
password
you enter a password once on each of
your devices and then you never have to
think about it again
dashlane protects your identity across
the internet by providing a tool
that generates strong passwords stores
them and autofills them securely
everywhere on the internet all
completely seamlessly
even across laptops and phones running
different operating systems
so even roger myers can't steal your
passwords
and for extra security dashlane premium
also includes dark web monitoring and a
vpn which acts as an intermediary to
make sure that all of your internet
traffic is encrypted
even when you're on public wi-fi
dashlane does all of this in one product
for one low price instead of requiring
you to buy multiple solutions
with dashlane you're getting a password
manager a vpn and
dark web monitoring for less than what
just one of those services would usually
cost
so try dashlane free for 30 days at a
link down below in the dooblydoo and if
you like it you can get 10
off dashlane premium by using the promo
code legaleagle at checkout
so do you agree with my grade leave your
objections in the comments and check out
my other real lawyer reactions over here
where i'll see you in court